so we can start right now
i love to party with
much
hi everyone welcome back to unwax i know
this is a
very different type of studio than
you're used to
and last week we did something with our
sister where we didn't have any video
but we decided
to power through and give you guys some
videos if you guys are watching right
now we look like
news anchors sitting next to each other
coming to you live
with this wax and wane of the week
um yeah we just did an interview with
hannah ann
very cute oh so pretty you guys will
love this interview it's going to come
after this
um we thought we'd just give you you
know the usual you know the routine you
know
a little weekly update um i feel like i
should just
kick it off i'm just gonna say guys
there ain't no wayne of the week
we've had a great week so far it's
friday when this comes out to me tuesday
but right now it's friday and we're
feeling good so you know
i feel like this is the first week in
quarantine that
we haven't had a wane progress
guys i don't know what it is but we've
been getting oh no i don't want to say
i'm going to jinx it if i say like that
we've been having good luck
knock on wood but we've been doing
pretty well so
applause for us so steve why are you
super happy this week
everyone if you're a true follower
of the unwax podcast you know you know
it's a dream of mine
to be tick-tock famous tik-tok
famous people i love sophia's giving me
like dramatic readings
i like echoing um no so
you know i was on my way out with sophie
and i did a
friend's youtube video and i was ready
and i looked good i was dressed
i go hey dad let's just make a really
you know
quick video it took 30 seconds to make
and it was my dad and i lip syncing the
song
cooler than me like if i could rat you
with something
she's been trying to convince us to
scarlet and i to do it for such a long
time
do you regret it no because i think that
everything happens for a reason i think
if it was
us three doing it it wouldn't have blown
up as much so let me tell you what
happened
i post the video phone is off for the
next six or seven hours right
and scarlett goes to steen look at your
phone
right now and i go huh and i go on my
tick tock you guys
and it had like two million plays and i
go what the hell this is crazy i was
freaking out right went to bed
woke up with 600 000 new followers
over 20 million plays and we're at like
4 million likes
what what what what
hold on hold on
what um
what oh you guys sophia just
did a spit take
okay so so um
i thought this is what i wanted i i
don't know how i feel right now
i thought this is what i wanted i
thought you would be power hungry
but she's i'm honestly a little bit
stressed and i sound so stupid i know
but i've never really received this much
well no no negative comments sophie and
i have always been lucky i was telling
my mom this the other day that
we have a big following but we've never
had some serious hate
and i've noticed with tick-tock comments
the reason why they're so there's so
much hate is because they're really
clever
and witty that the way that they write
their comments because those
comments want to be if you get the most
likes on a comment it goes to the top of
the
list so people try to out mean each
other in the most clever way
so that their comments are liked the
most right and whatever so
so sistine exposed herself to a whole
new world of tick-tock
hate i just want to the
i'll give an example um this is more
sounding like a wayne than a wax
well no i'm still really appreciative of
it but i just want this
this is an example i've never
experienced anything like this i thought
this was really funny this one comment
said um i went to school with her
or i went to middle school with her and
then a whole thread
below it is like what was she like was
she a
[ __ ] was she tell me tommy tell me and
this guy responds to this whole thread
like
oh yeah she had she's the most popular
girl in school
had like a hold on i know this is funny
had a whole group of friends
was kind of a [ __ ] all this stuff and
i'm
actually serious so i don't normally
respond to this sort of stuff did you
respond
i responded and i said to the guy
what school because we we jumped around
every two years so i said
what school he hits me back
and says uh you know like the one in
fourth grade so he's fully he's full of
[ __ ]
and by the way he's like living in
russia so i just don't know how that
would have even worked out wait did you
get did people comment from you
commenting on it
yeah no i yeah yeah so i called them out
and i love it i just wanted people to
understand like
that could not be further from the truth
christine didn't have a posse of friends
nor was cool no no you guys i wore
shoelaces that were hot pink and green i
wore knee socks
that had giraffes all over them and i
looked like a boy with side bangs like
it
was a hot mess i was the least cool
person also i feel like
if did we go to the same middle school
if you're thinking of the one that
it i met my friend that has a lot of
books
okay this school your group was yours
your class the class had like 12 kids in
it to form a group you have to be really
really cool of this 12 kids to put into
perspective
i was so uncool that i would trade
goldfish for pokemon cards you guys
this is not the most popular girl
talking right now like that so i just
thought that was really funny so
i'm curious now to see you know what
sort of
negativity comes along with it um i mean
i'm talking as if i've made it huge i
can't even imagine what like addison ray
and like charlie dimelio and those girls
with the insane amount of followers deal
with
i feel like the more that we're starting
to become on
air and doing this stuff is you get
we're getting a lot more responses than
we usually and people i think assume
that because we have a big following on
instagram that
we're gonna have like so many dms and so
much hate or so much love or like
a surplus of things but we have been
kind of lucky to
avoid all of that which has been great
yes we have our once in a while
horrible comment or horrible response or
dm whatever
but not as frequent enough to be like
like hit us in the car so i'm curious
and i'm trying to stop myself from
reading the comments like i'm really
trying
hard it's hard and also i like reading
what i liked about my tick tock before
was
i posted a lot of dorky stuff because no
one would view it
and now this morning i was like
archiving all of the stuff that i
thought was lame because i'm like oh my
god now i'm getting nervous that people
are gonna make fun of me i don't know
yeah
i gotta stay authentic though i don't
wanna change for anyone so i gotta
keep snapping myself out of it authentic
100 real speaking of 100 real
hear up face here down sweatpants city
come on this is probably the best part
about doing a zoom
right now is that we're half great why
is this like
i feel like you give me like this little
like i'm just listening to you i can't
tell if sister never is judging me or
not
does it look like she's judging me
i just have resting [ __ ] face you i
don't think you do
honestly do you guys think she's right i
don't think
do i sophia yes i do
you know we spent all morning um you're
getting scared
i will i forgot you were there you
scared me me too get rid of me on the
doom
you really scared me i'm not gonna last
like who is that
the voice of god that's it's the ghost
it's the fisherman it's the fisherman
ghost
um we spent all morning you guys getting
scarlett ready for her senior portraits
she's going to graduate high school she
looked really beautiful
yeah she did look good i'm really proud
of us we pulled it together and
we were like a glam squad you guys
diamonds for hiring both things like
we freaking slapped i did the makeups
it was freaking it was i'm gonna say
freaking one more freaking
[ __ ] great um i'm also excited for
this podcast
because the next few upcoming guests you
guys are
really good like sophia and i are so
excited not that the ones we had before
weren't good
but these upcoming guests i think you
guys will really like especially to the
ladies out there
i don't want to say and give it away now
but you're gonna love them
it's such an exciting few weeks coming
up and uh
yeah yeah so we are going to bring on
hannah ann right now so
sorry oh my god we're so bad at this ah
no we're great at it
but we're gonna bring on hannah ann
right now we had a really great
conversation with her
it was super fun really sweet as we said
before so
stay tuned okay okay i just want to say
right off the bat we're already making
jokes about the zoom interview
the top half of us is looking pretty
decent i'd like to say but we're all in
our sweats
from the waist down so i think we've uh
we've all sort of
started our friendship that way which is
just amazing yes
we've definitely broken the ice it's
like our honesty
now we're all honest here this is the
best part about having kind of
not that lockdown's a great thing but
you don't have to put an effort from
like the waist down or even like
eating wise i can just kind of let
myself go like here now i'm like okay
if i can contour really well i think i'm
good
i know i know exactly we don't have to
do as much
to ourselves i know so i'm just going to
give you a quick little introduction to
everyone
that does i everyone does know you
because you're literally like
we think you're honestly you're probably
our favorite person or a bachelor
really because you killed it on there
okay so
you may have watched her on the season
24 of the bachelor but this tennessee
girl has made waves since then she has
seen on numerous campaigns
increased her lifestyle brand instagram
to 1.3 million followers
and she continues to grow this is hannah
ann
did you like that was that good really
good i know i feel like i have a lot to
off i feel like i need to offer a lot
more now
no oh my god the fact that you showed up
and you look so cute is
you're doing enough so your accent is
adorable you moved from tennessee to la
how different are the people here that
you've noticed
oh yeah it very very different um
but i like it i've always like enjoyed
being around people that were
different than me because i grew up in
like the bible belt in the south
everyone read
things live the same life and so i
didn't really get to see
a variety of lifestyles like i would go
to the beach
once a year and then i would go to
disney world like every few years and
that was like my world i didn't like the
biggest thing
yeah yeah i didn't see a whole lot until
i got older that's how i started
models because i wanted to see i wanted
to be around people that like talk
different and have different points of
view yeah just to see the world so my
parents have never been to california of
course but hopefully
wait still today yeah no still today
they've never been
hopefully next year they can come out
and just
you know judge for themselves how
different it is oh my god you're so
you're so right about all of that
because la is such a melting pot of
people
like you're gonna see every type of
individual yeah
all here it's amazing i mean have the
people in terms like friendships been
different because i know that la and i
mean tennessee have to be kind of like
worlds apart in terms of like how you
hang out like what i mean
i feel like i'm so wrong maybe i'm this
is just my made-up
you know fantasy of what it is i feel
like the people in tennessee are
extremely like humble and kind and
and you know just just not so flashy in
your face and then la people
are you know the total opposite am i
sort of right
oh yeah no and there's nothing
necessarily wrong with it but like
moving here there were like some of the
things that people
you know value which you know are
awesome i didn't even know like existed
like different designers and like hotels
and like activities
like you do i'm like oh wow like it's a
completely different way of life a
different lifestyle
um but i've enjoyed being able to like
dabble in it a little bit but
thankfully like moving out here i
actually already had a friend group
because i as a model i traveled a lot
right
and so i had like my bible study group
out here and those girls
i mean they were like truly my saving
grace because when i moved here that's
when the pandemic happened and so
you're not really in a position to like
go out and meet new people
uh so i had like my friend group and
none of us have family here so
we've all come together that's the best
way to ease into any move is just having
your core group of friends that makes it
so much easier
um how are how different are the guys in
tennessee because i
as well feel like they're just going to
pull up and open the door
for you and call you ma'am and pull out
your chair where is that
we literally have not found one solid
guy here so far and we're both single
this is the first time we're really like
single together it's a it's hard
especially during pandemic and that's
when you moved here it's like
oh yeah absolutely one thing i have
realized
guys you're more aggressive but like in
the wrong way like you're walking
down the street and they're like honking
at you or like
number and i'm like sir you don't even
know my name but you're asking for my
number
exactly very aggressive and i
i don't know i have not been on a date
really since like may it's because like
there's no really no
i feel you i know it's time i've been
like on those dating apps for the first
time in our entire life i don't even
know why we decided to do this
during a pandemic but i'm not gonna like
ryan she's gotten hint
it's not going well i don't know did you
do dating apps or anything
no i'm not on any dating apps my friends
are and they'll tell me stuff about it
and i'm like i don't know i just feel
like it's already hard to find someone
that
likes you for who you are and not maybe
based on like your instagram profile
or or your background or
any of that i'm just trying to like meet
someone like at a coffee shop one day
and they have no idea they they don't
even like
know me on instagram at all never seen a
picture of we
we are so about the meat cube yeah all
we want to do is meet someone in an
elevator and fall in love and we push
the same button and that's what happens
have you been on a date in l.a where a
guy went after you because
of your following and you've been on tv
how was that
i i picked up on that just getting to
know guys
that live not just an ally just in
general i just feel like
if meeting through instagram at least
for me because i haven't been on any
dating sites
i don't know it's it's a little fishy
it's harder to figure out someone's
intentions now
yeah really it's just time that tells
with that
totally it's hard because i feel like
personally
when i since being in la and like
getting more involved in this whole like
social media world
you really can't tell if people are
being genuine to you because they want
to like
get clout or like some part of your
following and they could be really nice
but it could be kind of like four size
especially when you're going on dates
and like and then all of a sudden you
see a paparazzi behind a bush is that
that's what happens like i know she got
like when she was on dates like guys
i've had someone bring their resume
on a date for me so i would pass it to
my dad and i said sir
he won't even get me a job what makes
you think i'm gonna get you a job
oh my gosh and that's like not impress
you nor your parents
no not at all are your parents big on
um meeting the boyfriend or meeting a
guy are you guys very old school that
way
yeah yeah they are but now since like i
live across the country
well pretty much any guy aside from
peter that i have dated
they knew because they grew up in my
hometown and so now
a whole new territory of like next
person i bring
home they won't have any like background
on
you know they've been and probably will
be from like a completely different
background than me
right and speaking of even just like
that whole show like i don't even know
how
how did your parents feel about going on
the bachelor like i mean that's like so
different from probably what you guys
are like normally do like
it's normal i mean it's normal for not
anyone like in the first place just like
i want a dating show and like
have your dates be published yeah what
made you want to start the show
um i loved watching the show for like
years
and i thought peter webber i thought he
was so cute and i was like oh
this just seems like we could definitely
be a match why not yeah
and um actually my friend i don't know
if you know hannah g hannah godwin
she don't know we're buying a blonde
yeah yeah
so cute and she's getting engaged on
paradise
so prior to her even carrying in
bachelor nation we have been friends
and i remember like seeing her for the
first or the last time before she like
went off onto the bachelor she was on
holton's season season
and she had like such a overall great
experience and so she was like
encouraging me to do it and so i applied
and
got in and everything happened so fast i
really was
aware of it and they knew about panagia
and like
how many opportunities that brought her
and she ended up finding you know
her fiance yeah i love and my parents
were just like oh my gosh
this is so different than like really
good private
but my dad like i think my dad kind of
enjoyed it a bit because he had never
seen like production before or like
cameron
oh yeah fascinated like with the crew
like they kept making jokes that he
wanted to be a camera guy
oh have heard him bachelor hire
the dad that's so much nicer you
probably would have told you like red
flags like from writing
or if my dad was the cameraman he would
tell me if i look good at this angle
or if i need to blot my face i mean that
would be an advantage i have to give you
props because
i know for me if i was on the bachelor
and if i like initially saw the guy
let's say like on tv
you never know it's almost like a dating
app you see them on tv you see them like
their personality and you're like they
look
amazing like i can totally see me
reading them but then you meet them in
person like what if they like just suck
at kissing or like
what if they smell bad or like i don't
were you worried about those initial
things like did you feel
was there anything like that that right
off that you're like wait this may not
be the right one or
you don't have time it's not like set up
for you to
you don't have enough time like i we we
have
a ton of time but we don't have time
like we don't have a phone with tv we
don't have
music or any of but you're constantly
busy because we're like traveling the
world literally
which i feel bad for the guys on this
coming season yeah i know i can't
imagine and but you're just doing
interviews
all day long filming different scenes
they only show three percent
of what we film we film really all day
all day long wow was there something
that you found that you'd wish
made tv and it just got cut so much like
like what
um i wish more was seen when i was in
australia
like there were like a kangaroo date
where there was like these kangaroos at
an adoption center like i wish more of
that
it would have been yeah they'd do that
that would've been so much cuter
so you're were you 23 when you did the
show
yes i was 23. so you're very mature
for your age you're 24 now yeah you're
very mature in like the best way
possible but at 23 i couldn't even
imagine like
thinking about marriage so how did you
know that you were ready for a step like
that
i think it was my upbringing because
like i grew up like my parents got
married young my grandparents got me my
grandparents got married at like
as soon as they cut like 18. oh
a family thing yeah yeah it's it's just
like what you know
it's it's just kind of not expected but
you're like
born and then you're raised to become
you know a wife and a mom
right kind of like the foot you know
this it's a very cookie cutter
life so i felt like i was ready but
um i feel like everyone's on like their
own journey with that you know
yeah totally totally i i'm always
contemplating i'm like i'm ready now
let's have a baby and then i'm like hold
on i'm going to wait till i'm 45.
so i am all over the place and
especially in l.a it's hard to find
someone so
i know this process might take a little
longer
do you still feel that way like would
you still want to get married if you
found the one
soon yeah no i i definitely would uh
but at the same time just a little bit
of a little bit of me dabbling into
dating i'm like oh my gosh like this
that's not happening anytime soon it's
just so much
fun it is harder but i feel like do you
have like a certain type that you go for
like
looks wise personality type oh
so i feel like my type has changed as i
have changed
this whole year i walked into after
march after the show like i walked into
a whole new life like i moved to los
angeles i just had two suitcases
that's all i brought like that is making
me sweat
that's making me sweat oh my gosh um
with whatever i can
and that's when the pandemic happened so
i feel like um more like my needs and
what i
value is different than what i than
like my typical type that i've always
had right really it's more just
i'd value someone now especially that
has confidence that can handle
you know the public by someone that
could
you know support me along the way which
prior to that i wouldn't have even
thought of that
right i mean to be with someone sort of
in a similar position at like hannah for
example
i mean not hannah what's her name the
blonde is her name hannah yeah
oh hannah yeah um it's sort of it's nice
that they were both
on the bachelor and so they both
understand you know all of the
trials and tribulations that come with
it so would you consider doing bachelor
in paradise
no really why
i'm very happy with my life right now oh
that's great yeah i i'll never say never
to anything
i'll never say never but i'm really
happy with where life is at and
i'm very like content i can't i'm just
taking it one step at a time
you know for sure for sure but is there
anyone
in the bachelor world that if you could
maybe go on a date with
me for any season anybody even that you
think is like cute
from like season one it could be like
any season
i've always said um tyler c
i just always thought he was so good
yeah he's so cute
he's so handsome and he's like used to
be a model and
actually like his younger brother and my
sister have like
talked to people come on wait this is
kind of our dream situation you need to
go out with tyler because then it's just
a failing thing
double dates are going to be amazing for
you yeah
it could be but i also feel like with
bachelor nation we know so much about
each other
we're all kind of like kind of like a
graduating class you know how you
graduate high school oh that's a good
idea that's a good point
i feel like it's a good bad thing though
because i feel like everyone knows
everyone so it's like oh this person's
done this with this person
like bachelor nation seems like such a
tight-knit thing it's almost like yeah
like college like you're in a fraternity
or sorority house
everyone just kind of dates each other
and so you're like oh it could be good
because they get it
but on the other hand going to paradise
is like going back to college you know
oh right you're a super senior at this
point
that's so funny that's so funny is there
any sort of fun celebrity that has dmv
since the show
that you're like oh my god that's kind
of funny honestly
not not that i could really think of um
like ces had salt bae do you guys do you
remember that guy
yeah i got the guy that salt meats like
that's my coolest dm
do you all have any cool uh dm's that
come in from honestly
i wish i don't i always feel like i have
like an athlete that's on like a hockey
team that doesn't have a waterfall it's
always like random ones
yes yes right like the random ones or
it's like the well-known ones
and then like you do a little research
on they're like oh my gosh this guy's
like hitting up like
okay how many times right how many times
have you seen like these like
maybe nfl players like they'll dm me and
they don't have like a lot of followers
yeah
they have like a verified account and
then you go on their following and they
fell like
2 000 girls like we one percent of guys
you're like oh
i don't know if i'm ready for that yeah
i feel like if you
are trying to like investigate someone's
profile always go see who they're
following
you know a bunch of like girls
have naked photos on their instagram
you're like oh come on like this is way
too
i always do that yes or like
the bachelor if you see a guy they damn
me they go on they i see that
they're following all these other
bachelor girls i'm like oh i'm just
no no i totally got it i mean i'll look
at a guy's falling like oh my god he's
really cute and it's
every person he's following is just like
a blonde supermodel like
yeah this is not me why do you like me
yeah just not right um i want to go back
and talk about i was
we were doing some recon on you we're on
youtube watching all this stuff and
one of the most viewed videos is you
and peter and it was when i want to say
he said he broke off the engagement but
the way that you handled yourself in
that situation i mean you were
so strong and and so clear with your
words that it was one of those moments
where
you know you're having a conversation
with someone and then you go oh shoot i
wish i said that
you like said that and you said it so
well like for example you said a line
that said
either you don't mean your words or you
don't understand the weight of them and
how they impact people
like what the hell i wish i could see
how many times i've like broken up with
someone on the phone and i've
mumbled my words she's recording me
cracking up because i cannot get like no
but
i just i applaud you because you were so
well spoken and like
i feel like you were so empowering to
all women i
certainly like was empowered by it so
did you get a lot of
positive feedback from a lot of women
after that yeah i did
so when we broke up it was in late
january and i had to keep it
all a secret i couldn't i told one of my
bestest friends
everyone else i no one could know about
it so at first i was hiding
like an exciting secret because we were
engaged and then it became like a bad
secret like
and so having to like not live go
throughout life and not tell anyone on
top of that the show
airing it was just like it was really
like stomach turning
so when in march when i was able to like
cap off the show
it was not only great for me to like
move forward and not have to like
see him ever again or answer to anyone
the whole world was able to know so i
like really appreciated
everyone's support reaching out to me so
when the show had aired you guys were
currently broken up but it looked like
you were still together
we broke up with the middle of it um
so oh my gosh yeah i couldn't even
imagine people saying congrats on the
engagement you're like i'm actually not
even with this one
what do you think was the hardest part
about a breakup and what do you think
was like the best
part that helped you get over a break
because i couldn't imagine having a
breakup and it'd be
so public and i know like when i've had
my breakups they've been just so hard
and i've had to have my family around me
like
what has been the hardest part and what
has been like also the best part about
like having support me be around you the
hardest part was knowing that i had to
get through it so we broke up and then
it was like the clock was taking
five weeks until i saw him on national
television we did not speak
until that moment so it was more that
was the hardest part is like i couldn't
escape it you know when you have a
breakup you choose
and again yeah dudes if you want to
answer that phone call
or text that person back yeah that
choice i had to show
up and had
everyone else i didn't know like what
was going to be said or done oh my gosh
i mean your situation is so rare because
if i didn't want to see anyone i could
just ghost that person
ignore him but you had to come face to
face and and to the nation and to him
again and
sort of talk it all through was do you
almost wish that
you know that situation just was just
kept between you two or are you sort of
happy that you got your
your voice out there i had to keep a lot
confidential and so i'm glad that at the
end of it i was able to
um definitely point out some of the
issues that were never really
shined a light on well you know like
and so i'm glad i got to call him out on
it and that you know i move forward you
know don't talk about it i don't
i wish i could call people you're so
strong if everyone would feel like you
did this and just
everyone was on my top like side about
it so you say you're fully moved forward
what is the best piece of advice you
could give to men or women out there
that just need that extra kick in the
butt to move
move on from their person it's
not always the other person it you know
sometimes we can like misplace emotion
and i knew for me like i had to move
forward there was really no choice for
me
and it was up to me to create those
emotional boundaries
and setting those boundaries of you know
if you're going through a breakup don't
look at their pictures
unfollow them don't i mean that's not
being petty that's just moving forward
that's not
that's not reflecting on it um really
creating like a schedule was really
great for me
um i set aside like goals and things
that i could look forward to and be
excited about and also finding like a
trusted group of friends
that were going to encourage me to that
there were going to be better days ahead
because i love that i love that maybe my
um the whole idea of having a finsta
is a really bad idea because i stalk it
do you have a fenced up please tell me
i'm not the only one
my sister has a fence down do you have
her like you this is what i do
i use sofia to stock for me so i don't
sound so creepy
yeah no and like we've all been there
but every
i mean it's different for every person
for me that's just what i have found
to work that is like the healthiest
approach ever i'm gonna definitely take
a page out of your book
um speaking of health and lifestyle your
instagram
you're so fit and active and cute and
your body is absolutely beautiful
what have you been doing to stay fit
during quarantine
running like that yeah that's the key
yeah so when i moved here i was so
excited to be able to like get to know
my neighborhood
and i wasn't able to do that and the
only
opportunity i had was to go running so i
would just go out
i would run and then i would just like
look around like get to know my
neighborhood get to know where my
grocery store is and
be able to like sightsee like it was so
exciting for me to like see palm trees
that's like the best way to get to know
a new area too is just by
doing it on foot so running yeah that's
a great i've always been a chef
or cooking because i know you do a lot
of cooking on your instagram and they
look
amazing i want to try that lemon chicken
pasta i think oh yeah
that looks so bomb oh well which is
funny because i almost didn't even share
the recipe because i was nervous no one
was going to like it
i liked it i no i i shared a banana
bread recipe a while back i think i
deleted it
but i was so nervous that everyone would
do it and it would end up horrible
for them and then great for me and i'd
be like oh my god then my food tastes so
awful and they're never going to like
believe that again
yes yes for me i just always grew up in
the kitchen
i it's something my mom did my
grandmother did and it's more than just
like having something good to eat it's
like bonding
experience and so if anything
positive came out of quarantine it was
really that i was i kind of grew the
confidence to share it i didn't know
people were interested in like
my daily life and what i was eating so
it's kind of like
like basically snowballed into its own
like brand
opportunity for me so i'm excited just
to continue to share that it's something
positive that anyone can do at their
house
and i love that you're such a positive
role model for your followers
too i mean i think a lot of people i
don't think you realize how many people
like
like to follow and see what you do
because you do it so well is there
something that you like to do when you
just
i mean i know a lot of the time i'm like
oh my god i feel so fugly and like i
need to pick me up and i'll just
you know put a bunch of self-tanner on
and i'm like okay now i feel myself i
feel my best is there something you do
that gives you that sort of instant
glow-up um
glow-up i okay i love to do
a body scrub because the feel of soft
skin
especially right now in the winter like
every night
this i feel like a body scrub is so nice
i feel like your skin makes up
so much of your look just
nice and smooth and clear and i'm still
working on like my clear skin but i just
feel like that always makes me feel
my best yes yes i need to start
scrubbing off i have too many layers of
tan and now it's like clumping i'm like
okay
if i'm glowing down right now i'm
glowing down hard i made a little
question game we have a little
fun game we want to play with i call it
the five firsts
so i have five questions but you're just
gonna choose three numbers between one
and five and we're gonna answer three of
them all right so choose three numbers
between one and five um
i'll do three three okay the first time
you've been drunk
what was that experience like oh what
was that experience like
i i just laughed i just giggled yeah i
love that
i'm drunk i'm not like a mean drunk how
about another what's your number
next number yeah uh four three four okay
how about what was your first kiss
uh first kiss i was a freshman
in high school and it was when
there was nothing really to it it was
just like a kiss and then
my mom picked me up perfect my first
kiss was horrible and the worst part is
i'm still friends with this person today
so we still talk about yeah and we still
talk about
like how you know gross and sloppy it
was and i was like oh no no no it's so
funny
okay last number um one
okay worst first date
worst first date oh i know i have a good
one
oh i feel like it's so many of them
a worse first date um or you can just
name like a bad i can't think of one
just think of a bad date that you've had
okay uh there was oh yes okay
there was uh back in the spring going on
this one date with this guy
and all he wanted to talk about was the
show oh no
well is that like you know what kind of
questions did he ask you
just like how was it like how was it
being engaged and like
really dude how is it being engaged this
is a really big uh
turn off for me right now i'm not like
all the secrets of it all i'm like dude
there's no secrets
it's just weird because then it's like
oh you just want someone to get to know
you for who you are
you know or like or not more than just
a tv show i don't know it was really
weird
guys get it together come on act like
here's the tip for all men listening act
like you don't know anything about us
if you come in knowing things about us
already i've had a guy once tell me
the name of my ex i've had a guy tell me
about you know
family history and i said did you webmd
like what is going on like you
know it's deep stalking so yeah just
pretend like you don't know us and then
you know we'll believe you but hannah
thank you so
much for coming on the show today you
are absolutely like
a ray of sunshine you're so beautiful
plug all of your social so everyone
listening and watching can find you oh
yeah
um it's just instagram just hannah ann
stay with me honestly i don't use
anything else i don't use tick tock i
don't use facebook
i i'm on tick tock but i'm telling you
it's so hard
she just blew up on it so she's happy
but like
one oh here's like i didn't realize it
took one video with my dad to blow up
and that was that it was just like
cool easy done but i know i thought i
made some quality tick tocks for so long
and no one was liking them
and then all of a sudden i'll follow you
on tick tock and i'll go back and like
yes okay we're tick tock friends now you
guys this is a real friendship
in l.a well we're tick-tock friends it's
real hannah thank you again for coming
on
well thank you guys you guys are
beautiful and thank you
bye bye